the straft annual plan tracks our
progress as we move into the first year
of our long-term plan
since we adopted the ltp there have been
some changes in our operating
environment
and covett 19 continues to impact on our
community wellbeing
the good news is there is least economic
uncertainty and throughout the pandemic
we've seen continued growth and interest
from businesses looking to move to the
district
it's always important to the council
that we keep rates affordable and for
the coming year we've proposed a 4.3
rate rise which is in line with what we
predicted in the long term
plan the topics we want your feedback on
and this draft annual plan
focus on delivering high level
infrastructure
upgrading and building new community
facilities and protecting our
environment
we also want to bring you up to speed on
a number of different sector reforms and
new regulations which will change how
the council operates over the coming
years
your feedback will help us make the
decisions that reflect
what the community wants
make sure you have your say we'd love to
know what you think